[Musique]
oui
com
bon ça vous êtes nombreux à vous allez
bien vous me demandez pas comment je
vais du coup
non merci c'est spontané ça fait plaisir
ça va ça va je suis à vous je suis
timide donc là ça passait pas facile
pour moi
papy m'a jeté sur scène pour venir vous
parler ce soir je vais vous parler de la
vie d'artiste alors c'est un vaste sujet
quand même un la vie d'artiste on n'a
pas tous la même
je vais vous parler de ma vie d'artiste
je n'ai pas exactement la même que
monica bellucci par exemple à pied alors
j'ai préparé quelque chose parce que
vous parlez des choses comme ça ça va
être compliqué je suis très bordélique
elles montrent patte a appelé ça le
bordel intuitif c'est le cousin éloigné
du bordel organisé ça resterait moins
organisés de toute façon je suis
tellement pas organisés pour vous dire
dans ma vie privée sentimentale j'ai dû
m'organiser pour les garçons je fais une
playlist et j'écris oui ou non en bresse
de chaque prénom comme j'ai écrit non en
face de tous les prénoms je me suis dit
ça fonctionnait pas bien donc j'ai opté
pour une méthode plus psychorigide et
militaires parce que je suis petite
fille de militaire nous je fais comme
pour les déchets les poubelles avec les
déchets le tri sélectif
alors j'ai créé quatre types de
poubelles sur mon ordinateur alors la
poubelle jaune
donc ça c'est la grosse savait toujours
en bordel pour le carton le recyclable
donc ce sont les histoires
potentiellement reconductible
par exemple un mec mac et un extrait
chauffer voyez une relation officielle
pas stable on reste en bons termes
parce qu'on sait jamais il ya toujours
moyen de faire un plan cul avec c'est un
défi qu'on peut optimiser dans le temps
ensuite la poubelle verte
donc ça ce sont les déchets dits
organique l'organe principal étant le
sexe ayant déjà pas mal servi je peux
plus rien faire c'est mort fini nos
verts et au bout d'un moment si je jette
pas assez vite ça sent pas très bon à
écouter
voici celle que ça la poubelle avère
alors ça c'est ma préférée c'est là tout
petit vous savez toujours trop plein qui
vous vous la montre le matin quand vous
vous essayez de passer inaperçu pour vos
voisins pas passer pour une grosse poire
astres avec le bling bling c'est sans
bling-bling bonjour bingbing oulala ça
fait du bruit au bling bling bling
bompas à celle entre deux poubelles
c'est aussi recyclables comme le carton
donc au final j'y retourne toujours
selon le garde sous le coup de la
relation et enfin la dernière puis en
plus c'est dans l'air du temps le
compost voilà on est dedans quand même
nom sur du déchets en décomposition
c'est vraiment l'histoire qu'on n'a
jamais envie de voir revenir dans sa
ville à laquelle on n'a jamais envie de
retourner non plus par exemple pervers
narcissique
je patiente dans la salle mais ils
dénonceront pas toutes façons en moi ça
moi j'ai arrêté un pareil
le mec qui me demande ma brosse à dents
le lendemain matin à vous avez vous
assez d'accord avec moi j'ai des toques
imaginer que je prête pas ma brosse à
dents même à un mec super sympa et alors
moi je suis tombé sur un mec qui
souffrait de gamme momani ce que
quelqu'un sait ce que c'est eh ben vous
avez de la chance c'est un mec qui
demandent leur mariage la première venue
donc ouais tu me plais on se marie non
et cinq minutes après il a demandé à ma
copine dont je me suis dit mon mec est
pas fiable quand même voilà au poste et
en plus cumuler problème parce que je
suivais gagnent mais de la tob excusez
moi je serais vous choque pas trop alors
j'ai créé ça peut servir à deux
personnes j'ai créé une norme spéciale
face à une certification dpf bon pour
fellation s'il n'a pas la mention vpf
moi je la mets pas dans ma bouche en
voit la balle à son parti en couille là
je savais que j'allais partir en vrille
vous avez vu je suis bordélique faut
alors je vous compte sur vous pour me
canaliser si vous voyez je pars en brie
n'hésitez pas à me le dire
d'accord parce que j'étais là pour
parler la vie d'artiste donc la vie
d'artiste règle numéro une dans la vie
d'artiste savoir se mettre à nu alors on
pourrait presque aller dire à poil
mais ne faites pas comme moi ne prenez
pas les termes au premier degré moi la
première de mon spectacle
j'ai fait une affiche à poil j'ai joué à
moitié nue et j'ai appelé ça public
voyez la cohérence des fruits quand même
voilà la fiche à poil c'était quand même
pas totalement de mon fait
mon producteur a dit écoutez les thés
comédienne alors la base quand et
comédien c'est de savoir se mettre à
poil
si c'est pas mettre tout nu batak le
métier tout de suite mon jour à qui ça a
fait débat entre le producteur et le
metteur en scène
bon sur la fiche on hamm est de dos en 2
face à la panne bichon ça sert à rien
et il faut qu'on montre la photo faut
qu'on voit son cul sur la photo robin
non on ne peut pas faux blessés faut
baisser mois en fait je pense que je
suis quand même c'est moi qui ai créé ce
spectacle c'est mon corps mon cul donc
non pas ta gueule tu penses pas tu joues
c'est pas ta partie ok bon elle m'a
coupé le disait quoi arrêt avec ou sans
l'arrêt la marge de discussions n'a pas
été très large
c'est important de ne pas surinterpréter
n'est jugée trop vite c'est comme si moi
je marche dans la rue je vois un panneau
au pub vous savez sur les boutiques on
dit aussi que c'est open je prends un
petit coup de bits
bonjour bonjour madame alors elle
prendra quoi la petite dame géant mais
combien d'un mois ainsi possible voire
deux parce que vous avec ou sans contact
avec c'est quand même plus sympa non la
carte comptable tout sens oui j'avais
pas compris donc vous prêtez pas trop
vite
voilà et donc on va passer à la règle
numéro deux il faut ne pas être
susceptible dans ce métier et ne pas se
formaliser
quand vous faites ce métier vous avez
beaucoup de critères physiques vous j'ai
eu voilà on vous diront vous dépeint
vous savez à quoi vous ressemblez après
par exemple sur les énoncés de casting
vous avez trompés au type méditerranéen
caractère volcanique peau mate
bon jusque là ouais après tout ce qui
est moi par exemple profit charlotte
gainsbourg général j'y ai droit entendre
par la morphologie androgyne
ou alors vous n'avez pas forcément belle
mais a du charme
ok dont je parle du postulat de base que
je suis pas très très belle bosse sur un
malentendu éventuellement non mais je
suis pas susceptible c'est pas grave y'a
pas de problème
après j'ai eu des nausées de casting
aussi profil sportive épaules carrées
bonne tête visage buriné a failli voir
le terme buriné savais pas ce que ça
voulait dire avant
reid et énergique ouais portant sur elle
et vicissitudes de la vie
ouais grave et au burin ah ouais pareil
mon visage là n'est plus sûr du btp et
ravalement de façade ne suis pas
susceptible encore une fois un après
dans la publicité vous avez des dress
code pour aller au casting par exemple
pour vous dit venir en tailleur ou on
décontracté en jean
maman un jour on m'a dit de venir en
maillot de bain une pièce moi je ne sais
pas vous mais moi c'est longtemps que
j'ai arrêté mes bonnes pièces un ça
écrase le peu de poitrine qui émerge de
mon corps qui essaye en tout cas donc je
partais pas hyper gagnante au casting et
j'y allais pour jouer un rôle d'ancienne
surfeuse on voit tout de suite le profil
californien donc je me suis dit à défaut
je vais peut-être pouvoir jouer la
planche de surf
alors quand même repartir sur la règle
numéro 3 il faut savoir s'adapter dans
ce métier on vous demande pas si vous
avez des toques des tarés des phobies
bon ben moi je cumule les 3 je souffre
de cinétose et des aérodromes aux
phobies alors le deuxième vous allez
sans doute deviné
j'ai peur de l'avion et lassiné tôt ça
n'a rien à voir avec le milieu du cinéma
c'est beaucoup moins glamour j'ai le mal
des tous les transports ils tous sans
exception et dans ce métier on voyage
beaucoup
donc un jour j'ai enfin été prise pour
faire une publicité télévisuelle j'étais
super contente
si l'école
et on m'a appelé trois jours avant pour
m'annoncer que je parte à bangkok paris
bangkok
11h30 d'avion à j'étais entre la joie et
la désespoir je vous le dis tout de
suite pourquoi pas à la
plaine-saint-denis c'était quand même
tout près alors j'ai vomi à peu près 10
heures sur 11h30 je ne pouvais rien
faire parce que je ne peux absolument
rien faire pendant que j'ai peur et en
plus j'ai mal au coeur
tout le monde dort bien profondément les
seuls mecs qui étaient réveillés ce un
steward taille
j'ai parlé ni anglais ni français alors
je lui disais désespérément est fluide
liz may souriait si je teste j'ai une
bombe sur moi toujours il me sourit donc
à ilm avec ne comprend pas un pays donc
j'ai vécu ce voyage avec beaucoup de
douleur je suis arrivé enfin en
thaïlande 40° paysages exotiques je me
dis voilà on arrive dans le vif du sujet
j'étais payé pour voyager ça c'est quand
même bien dans mon cas c'est indiqué
j'arrive en thaïlande je vous dis
chouette
et ben non je tournais dans un studio
c'est dommage d'avoir fait autant de
souffrances pour si peu et je venais
tourner une pub pour la cua poney
comment ça tu veux me mettre vraiment
dans la piscine avec ton ponelle as
qu'il aseptisé je rappelle que j'ai des
toc qui gênait microbes
ça ne me tente moyens mais il rigolait
pas moi je ne vais jamais à la piscine
municipale
la seule fois où je suis allé dans une
piscine à paris j'ai fait l'effort
surhumain d'y aller je me suis retrouvée
ne croyez ou pas et c'est vrai à côté
d'une merde humaine qui flottait à côté
de moi qui me regardait comme ça car il
fait toute la piscine pour venir me
traumatiser alors là je savais plus dans
quelle direction nager je me suis jeté
de l'eau comme une otarie et je vais
aller me désaffectée à la bétadine de
trois fois donc voilà vous imaginez le
traumatisme donc après les mains dans
une piscine avec un trône est bon mais
bon c'est comme ça
j'étais payé encore une fois est bien
payé donc j'ai accepté
et puis quand on fait une publicité par
exemple on commence à travailler dans ce
métier on commence à acquérir une
certaine notoriété de connu et reconnu
ça c'est bien après il ya des moments
dans la vie on n'a pas forcément envie
d'être connu sortez que les réseaux
sociaux maintenant on est exposé un peu
partout il ya toujours quelqu'un pour
nous nous cramer donc le jour de mon
accouchement ça m'a poursuivie quand
même meilleur moment
je suis arrivée à l'hôpital quand même
en urgence mon bébé était pronostic
vital engagé moi aussi et là le
personnel médical réagi ouais vous êtes
madame julia vous êtes l'urgence du jour
oui j'ai lâché la meuf avons vous comme
une merde or rose elle vous est grave la
gueule mais bon elle elle va s'en sortir
ça va emma attendez je vous regarde
votre tête là me dit quelque chose
meiway big up le 23 vous avez fait la
fiche du comité départemental du
tourisme de la creuse et vous êtes
égérie de la creuse elles font décoller
jeune actrice hommes à tous mes potes ça
fait plaisir vous voir assez cool on
peut vous parler tout c'est sympa mais
je dois abusé là je sais que c'est pas
le meilleur moment pour vous mais l on
peut faire un petit selphy tous les deux
ouais la crise représente aller pack
assez cool en remercie moi je vais quand
même là c'est chaud pour vous je vais
aller chercher à chef de clinique
bonjour vous êtes le nen milliards oui
bonjour moi c'est claudine la cheffe de
clinique votre prénom c'est hélène à
c'est très joli et elle j'aime beaucoup
c'est très doux mon arrière grand mère
s'appelait comme ça elle est décédée
bon alors si je suis là aujourd'hui en
fait c'est que bon le rythme cardiaque
de votre bébé et la normale vous n'allez
pas trop fort et l'aisne
on reste avec moi mais coûte on écoute
les sons à voix haute voix de ce passé
un sale moment de me lâcher bon vous n'y
mettez pas du vôtre vous n'avez aucune
contraction le col et tonique et fermez
votre chatte beaucoup trop étroite pour
faire passer un bébé vaud qui va falloir
procéder césarienne en urgence mais
attendez vous épaule car hélas votre
carrière sportive votre visage buriné ça
me dit quelque chose
nicole vient voir à nicole via regarde
la dame cla c'est vous qui avez fait la
pub pour la cua poney à la la ben oui
mais ce dico l'émoi en fait de la
connais tous les week-ends ma fille est
inscrite à la cua poney vous êtes un peu
notre idole ai je fait abuser bon ma
fille vous connaissez les réseaux
sociaux tout ça elle serait ravie qu'on
fasse un petit selphy toutes les trolls
indique al viens avec nous à l'est ça
vous dérange pas et les noms on nous
lisions sourit quand même à fond
allez voila voila mon la notoriété ça a
du bon et du mauvais quand même alors
règle numéro 4 houssam je ne sais plus
trop coucher utile bah oui quitte à
coucher où tant que ça nous serve un
mois j'ai bas d'ailleurs toujours les
mêmes producteurs qui non content de
m'avoir mis à poil un jour m'a envoyé à
un joli petit message je vous le donne
ou pas ne soyez pas choqué il m'a écrit
si tu sais tenir talent que je sortirai
m'habite attendait rigolez pas ça fait
un alexandrin à pied près le mec c'est
quand même foulée c'est un poète alors
bon autant vous dire je les dis à tous
paris 1
je me suis empressé d'appeler mon
metteur en scène papy hashtag me two way
we et puis tu sais bien que je suis
vegan moi il n'est pas certifié bpf je
suis pas d'accord
voilà voilà bon donc j'hésite à créer
l'association ni [__] ni soumises
quand on se fait t'il quand même c'est
compliqué bon je vais passer à la règle
numéro 6 il faut avoir de l'autodérision
dans ce métier et savoir être humble en
vous n'allez pas tout de suite être
premiers rôles à d'abord vous ferez des
figurations les apparitions
alors moi j'ai été doublure dhombres
derrière une fenêtre de dos de nuit
je suis ravi d'avoir fait conservatoire
et trois ans de cours d'art dramatique
j'ai fait aussi beaucoup de figuration
prostituées ou macchabées sa part ça
fait plaisir mais attention un jour on
m'a dit à ma maman tu fais une
prostituée mais c'est une roumaine qui a
voyagé 15h en soute à ya du jeu ah oui
oui d'accord
non mais là je comprends bien puis alors
un jour j'ai été mannequin pour toshiba
par là je me dis lueur d'espoir quand
même la classe
pas du tout j'arrivais dans une clinique
on m'a allongé sur un brancard j'ai
tester du matériel d'échographie pour
toshiba quand même
hélas les bonnes femmes de pousser un
cri sme olala moniot merde alors on va
le découvrir en plus un problème médical
mais vous avez une très belle rate et
oui ça va me servir dans mon métier de
comédienne s'achever châtain lieu vers
belle rate on sait jamais ça peut pas
que de faire décrocher un rôle
ouais ouais bon alors parlant de taille
tout ça de poids et de critères
il ya encore une règle qui est très
importante c'est d'avoir un profil
stable on a compris que la stabilité
s'était pas mental comprend bien que
c'est pas très stable de stabilité
physique
vous avez des critères à respecter tour
de poitrine mensurations tout ça cheveux
couleur de cheveux dieu change pas tous
les quatre matins en même temps donc si
vous vous présentez comme ayant un
profil valérie lemercier faut pas que ça
soit brigitte fontaine qui arrive au
casting quoi ça fait pas du meilleur
effet alors j'ai testé pour vous si vous
voulez l'été c'est chez vous un jour de
régime il ya le rib le régime interdit
bancaire
matt a pas d'argent tu bouffes pas basse
assez radical 5 10 kilos en moins
ensuite c'est le régime fous l'camp
basé sur la technique du sav la
séparation amoureuse volontaire des de
mec t'as rien faire mais tu le largue
comme une merde et hop tu fais une
petite dépression pareil
quelques kilos en moins bon ça peut vous
servir voilà bah écoutez eux j'espère
vous avoir fait rêver sur le métier
d'artiste
n'hésitez pas à penser à moi quand vous
jetterez vos poubelles et si vous avez
besoin de conseils n'hésitez pas aussi à
faire appel à moi vous voyez que j'ai
quand même aguerris dans le milieu alors
juste pour voir si mes conseils et
efficace est ce que quelqu'un se
souvient de la règle numéro une
on va pas qui je crois qu'il faut que je
travaille un peu je me suis pas canalisé
canaliser faut dire à jeter pas hyper
organisés voilà bon m numéro deux au
hasard sait jamais peut-être que non
quelqu'un s'en souvient bon bah disons
le four vous souvenez de regarder ce que
je vous ai dit est ce que quelques noms
bpf peut-être non les bons le régime
vous connaissez la creuse c'est très
joli moi j'ai passé mon permis de gama
j'étais là-bas alors ça n'a rien à voir
avec une voiture de rallye c'est pour
tester le niveau du foie donc qu n'y a
pas grand-chose à faire part enfin jeu
j'aime la creuse un jeu précise j'ai des
amis là-bas
j'aimerais pas que mes mettre à dos mais
on peut boire de 12h à 22h à l'aise en a
pas refaire de la coi pour
éventuellement et quelqu'un fait de la
cua poney ici parce que bara voyez vous
non plus vous n'avez pas envie d'aller
dans l'eau avec un poney 1 à la limite
une rivière mais alors une piscine messi
a dû clore quand même bon bah écoutez je
sais pas je pense que je vais laisser la
place à au suivant si personne ne me
retiens voilà merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors elle m c'était très intéressant
sur cette vie d'artiste je pense que du
coup tout le monde est décidé à ne pas
devenir artiste et bien bravo
il ya plein de parents qui sont heureux
de ce qu'ils ont entendu parce que leur
enfant qui voulait peut-être artistes
seront pas hélène c'était une première
ce soir parce que je sais oui tout à
fait je sais pas grandie sais pas c'est
fou ça
son metteur en scène un cellulaire une
actualité d'approché n'allait pourra te
voir très prochainement
oui je dirais vous au mois de mars au
mois de mars
oui un set prochainement mais il faudra
être un peu plus précis peau public
si le chat de cette année c'est à dire
mais ça reste encore un grand suspense à
le suspense reste entier et donc on suit
son actu sur les réseaux sociaux est
exactement sur hélène bulliard par
exemple
voilà par exemple mon prénom est mon nom
et merci l année merci merci'
applaudissements
[Musique]
à
paul bigard
[Musique]